joining me now is former senior military
intelligence and security adviser Philip
Ingram Phillip it's good to have you
here with us what's the significance
then of Putin's visit well Putin he's
been in a special military operation now
for 388 days this is the first time that
he's visited
um Russian occupied elements of Ukraine
um after visiting Crimea yesterday which
was on the ninth anniversary of Russia's
illegal invasion in 2014. so he's
sending two messages out one to the
International Community this
international criminal court
um
order out to arrest me is something that
I'm not bothered by and that's in a
message to president Xi Jinping as well
who's visiting Moscow and Vladimir Putin
tomorrow and then sending a message to
his domestic audience saying I'm the the
leader here this is part of Russia and
therefore I will happily go and visit if
he actually did
very interesting isn't it oh what's the
situation on the ground more broadly yes
well more broadly we've got Vladimir
Putin going into allegedly into Mario
Paul
um as we can see where it is there and
Mario Paul itself was significant you
know 90 of the buildings have been
damaged 350 000 out of half a million
people
um were moved out of the city
um the azov Battalion held out in the
azov style works for
um 83 days almost three months and and
that hit the news so that's quite
significant militarily and politically
um but then from a wider military
perspective we're still focused on
Batman we've still got the Wagner
private military company
um focused in there but they seem to be
fixed in place you know they've tried to
attack in there was rumors of a spring
offensive that hasn't happened
ukrainians have reinforced to a degree
and seem to be holding the Russians
there and again down in the vulador area
and and
um wider donetskaria um the the normal
Russia in conventional military have
been attacking out ukrainians are
holding them in place and have destroyed
some of their better formations or the
ones that have been left